pues bien en términos generales yo creo
que si te estaba explicando que nuestro
abogado fue muy
y eficiente en explicar a los jueces
nuestro argumento
qué consiste no necesariamente en
ejecutar los bienes de seguro en canadá
directamente como que se bronca nada
sobre una empresa deudora sino ejecutará
según canadá en sí misma como que fuera
parte de los bienes de ese gran
corporation nuestro abogado le sugirió a
los jueces canadienses que hagan dos
preguntas de los abogados de chevron y
estas preguntas son muy importantes y
dejan ver lo que está detrás de toda
esta discusión una de las preguntas era
sí
estaría bien si fuera posible para ellos
preguntan los abogados de chevron si
sería posible ejecutar las acciones de
chevron canadá si es que esta empresa
canadiense fuera una subsidiaria directa
de hebrón corporation eeuu
los abogados de chevron canadá
respondieron que sí
en todo aquí de lo único que estamos
atrás de cuál es la diferencia que
podemos tener
cuando hay seis niveles de subsidiarias
en lugar del grupo sol
y esta es la típica estructura
corporativa que utiliza en este tipo de
estacionales siempre para guiar sus
inversiones de lo que estamos hablando
aquí no es simplemente de a quién le
pertenece si es utilizar la separación
corporativa como una especie de
barrera intransitable dependiendo de
cuántos niveles de subsidiarias haya
porque sepa los abogados no está bien
que se ejecute sí sí sí sé bronca nada
fuera propiedad directa del cero
corporation pero no está bien que sepa
si es que hay seis niveles de
subsidiarias en la mitad el punto de
discusión parece ser
la separación corporativa